ce spectacle là ils ne sont que
quelques-uns à y avoir droit
actuellement
et parmi eux aline peltier aline et la
directrice de l'observatoire
volcanologique de la réunion
elle est l'une des rares à avoir les
clés de l'enclos du piton de la
fournaise la clé du paradis en route
pour la deuxième éruption de cette année
bon allez en fin de partie aline peltier
à 36 ans elle est la première femme à
diriger l'observatoire volcanologique
après y être arrivé comme stagiaire en
2003 ma passion est née très tôt à l'âge
de 15 ans j'ai eu la chance de faire une
colline vacances en italie
elle accueille vacances passées par la
sicile et par ses volcans actifs comme
l'etna et le stromboli et j'ai la chance
de voir ces deux volcans en éruption et
depuis ce jour là elle et tous ont voulu
en savoir plus sur les volcans et je
vais faire ce métier de volcanologues
depuis aline n'a cessé d'arpenter les
portes escarpées du piton de la
fournaise
si on fait un calcul rapide par sortie
une quinzaine de kilomètres je dirais
peut-être 500 par an je suis
observatoire depuis 2003 pourquoi dire
des miniers et une quinzaine de
kilomètres aujourd'hui encore avec un
gros dénivelé
car avant de rejoindre le site de
l'éruption aline et patrice un des
ingénieurs de l'observatoire vont aller
prendre des mesures sur une dizaine de
stations humaines du satellite
c'est quoi tout ce matos alors c'est la
station gps qu'on va mettre sur la
petite île ici donc ça gps haute
précision qui va nous permettre en fait
de voir de manière extrêmement précise
comment à bouger ses tiges pendant
l'éruption sachant que pour chaque
élection générale et chaque tige bouge
entre quelques centimètres et quelques
dizaines de centimètres
tous les deux ou trois cents mètres en
montants toujours plus haut aline et
patrice vont ainsi mesurer les
mouvements de terrain provoqué par
l'éruption
afin de mieux comprendre la trajectoire
du magma arrivé à 2600 mètres
ils posent leurs sacs pour descendre à
l'intérieur du cratère bory
au total 80 tiges de mesures équipe le
site du piton de la fournaise auxquels
il faut ajouter les stations permanentes
comme celle installée au bord du cratère
dolomieu véritable coeur du volcan
avec ses équipements bien que le top
mondial puisque on a une fontaine de
capteurs permanent sur site
non la station qui est derrière nous et
ce qui fait qu'on est le volcan le plus
densément équipé au monde
on va à rapprocher un peu mais pas trop
quand même
hop
attention attention parce que c'est un
endroit là vous voyez beaucoup de
fractures mais surtout bye bye et un
précipice de 300 mètres juste à côté
nous donc on va passer s'approcher plus
qu'on n'a pas d'équipement de sécurité
aligne pour alan juste pour info c'est
le dernier point sommet et on commence à
descendre deux rivales ça ce moment on
aperçoit seulement au loin les panaches
de fumée de l'éruption
commence alors une longue et difficile
descente sent-il qu un appui
allez c'est parti les lapilli sont des
fragments de l'avs éjecté par le volcan
mais le plus dangereux ce sont les
grattons surtout quand ils sont récents
comme dans ce passage délicat
d'où les gangs finalement que la roche
volcanique plus de 50% c'est de la
silice donc c'est comme du verre donc si
on me pose sa main on se coupe
donc c'est important de mettre des gants
des cons dès qu'on touche le la roche
volcanique et c'est ainsi que finalement
peindrai voir pas mal là je pense
l'équipe arrive le premier point de vue
sur les ruptures donc le site et un
petit
ça a bien changé commun car ce matin une
seule bouche éruptive semble encore
actives
alors qu'il ya 48 heures trois caunes
projetait de la lawe celui du bas
apparemment donc c est un n'y a plus
rien qui s'échappe celui des eaux
donc elle plus proche de nous et
rougeoyant mais a plus du tout de
projection et seul celui du milieu en
fait continue d'avoir des projections
plus on approche et plus le volcan fait
entendre ses grognements quelques
centaines de mètres encore à travers les
grattons et aline et patrice rejoignent
le site de l'éruption
à peine le temps de reprendre leur
souffle
et il s'élance vers la gueule du loup
objectif recueillir les projections de
lave qui vole à présent tout autour
d'eux ce n'est pas pour rien qu'on les
appelle des bongo
tu as roi a battu
attention ça dégueulasse
on a reculé un peu
il
sa mère
q
toujours d'ailleurs
on m'a surpris un peu tout
à tokyo
[Musique]
allingham une grosse prise de risque non
chaque grosse explosion seront trian par
doris bien sûr parce qu'il prévoit
toujours une position plus importante
que les autres
attention
toujours derrière
la prison d'athènes mais bon non jamais
non mais comme je dis quand l'explosion
a lieu parce qu'un assez dispersé si tu
fais attention tu peux passer entre
après tu peux recevoir des petits
fragments c'est pour ça qu'il faut voir
des manchons il faut avoir des gants ni
physique peut avoir un casque on a des
échantillons
souvent tout chaud c'est l'échantillon
et qui peut nous apprendre
c'est gentil on va être envoyés en
métropole pour analyse et nous ça va
donner une information sur la
composition chimique et sur la
provenance de ce magma voir sur notre
alimentation nouvelles ou si ça a été
stocké l'otan en profondeur et dans ce
cas là on aura une tétée être une petite
idée
si on aura une année 2010 8 active ou si
ça s'arrête rapidement cote très bonne
récolte ce qu'on a pu faire tout ce
qu'on voulait on a combien des champions
là on a cinq six échantillons doit de
bonne taille
bonne journée et pour que le plaisir
soit total
c'est à ce moment précis que dans la
lumière dorée de cette fin d'après midi
la lave se remettent à couler le
spectacle pourrait durer plusieurs
semaines encore il peut aussi s'arrêter
en quelques secondes
[Musique]